y Comencemos por hablar de qué hay
detrás realmente de estas órdenes de
cerrar páginas y cuentas
Buenas tardes pues lo primero lo más
importante es que en un momento de un
desastre natural la información es
sensible y por eso es importantísimo que
la ciudadanía se informe por los canales
de rigor por los canales periodísticos
el problema de Turquía es que el régimen
de allí verdogán es ya un especialista
en reprimir la la libertad de expresión
es un país donde se encarcela a los
periodistas por ser críticos y lo que no
puede ocurrir es que se aproveche una
situación tan dramática como este
terrible terremoto para
cercar aún más a la prensa libre a
restar a periodistas acusarles de
difamar a la policía y al estado y En
definitiva Bueno pues intentar aún más
convertir toda esta tragedia nacional y
todo este desastre en una forma de
reprimir y de y de oprimir a la
población y sobre todo
oprimirla y reprimir la libertad de
prensa no Turquía está en el en el
puesto 149 de los 180 de la
clasificación mundial de reporteros Sin
fronteras y eso es porque son unos
especialistas en generar todo esa toda
esa esa represión en torno en torno a la
información de rigor y veraz y usted
reitera que el gobierno de
reyertaiberdones experto en esto y de
hecho no es la primera vez que pone
estas restricciones ni que usa la
desinformación como una justificación
para actuar y es que en octubre del año
pasado el parlamento Turco aprobó una
ley que permite que periodistas y
usuarios de redes sociales sean
encarcelados hasta por tres años por
difundir información falsa que tan en
riesgo Entonces está la libertad de
expresión con esta medida de octubre y
ahora con lo nuevo que están haciendo
tras los terremotos
Claro en una situación crítica en un
estado de emergencia en una catástrofe
natural tan tan grave es como que
ciertos gobiernos con
ínfulas autoritarias se creen con con
más razón o con más manga ancha con más
margen para poder recortar derechos
fundamentales y ellos ya tienen ese
armazón legal lo hicieron previamente no
hay que olvidar que que erdogan se
enfrenta este año a elecciones y por eso
quiere tener Y es forma parte de su
estrategia controlar a la a la prensa en
este momento hay 23 periodistas
encarcelados y toda esta situación
dramática pues le está sirviendo para
para cortar las redes sociales para
cortar la conexión a Twitter en un
momento que la gente necesita
información de rigor Y eso no significa
que no haya que perseguir Y condenar a
aquellos que en momentos críticos pues
intentan aprovecharse también de esta
situación y bueno robar donaciones o o
perpetrar no cualquier tipo de de
atentado no contra contra la población
civil online online pero pero desde
luego erdogan es un especialista y
Turquía un lugar donde los derechos
fundamentales y desde luego la libertad
de prensa no se respeta